so how did you check that your code
worked hopefully you did check that the
conference keys to attend contains the
conference key string and you shouldn't
have found the conference keys to attend
contain the conference name because it
doesn't so another good thing to check
is that after you register for a
conference the seats available goes down
by one so the first time you register
the seats available it's going to go
down by one less than the max it and
ease of course if you log out log in as
a different user and then register for
the same conference again seats
available is going to go down by even
more than one less than the max of 10 DS
and yes in our application you can
register for a conference you created ok
so let's take a quick look at the
finished code for register for
conference and we're in the conference
API class here you already know if the
users now throw an unauthorized
exception here we start the transaction
off your transact and then here we do
the public wrapped boolean run wrap
boolean is what we're going to return we
get the conference key we just load the
conference from the datastore should be
familiar with doing that by now it says
no conference found take the appropriate
action get the users profile from the
data store check the various conditions
before we allow the user to register
then it all looks good go ahead and book
the seat so we add the conference key to
the conference keys to attend property
of the profile we book the seats on the
conference and then very importantly we
save the profile and the conference and
we return the wrapped boolean and if we
didn't get a success throw the
exceptions we already talked about that